J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: We're
talking about alkenes,
and in particular today,
we're going to be continuing to
talk about
polymerization in the context of
things that nature makes,
which are called isoprenoids.
And then we'll, talk about the
properties of polymers, and
then go onto acetylenes.
We're talking about
electrophiles being the things
that attack double bonds, in
particular, ones where the
electrophile is carbon, like the
sigma-star of something
with a leaving group on it, or
with an electronegative group
on it, or a cation.
We're talking about the
synthesis of
terpenes and steroids.
There's a key molecule called
isopentenyl pyrophosphate:
pyrophosphate is this thing with
two phospohorouses linked
by an oxygen.
It turns out you can do an
allylic rearrangement I mean,
when I say you, I mean you I
mean the enzymes in you do it.
So you can get from isopentenyl
pyrophosphate to
dimethylallyl pyrophosphate,
which you know involves a
shift of hydrogen allylically.
Now, the reason you do that is
to make it
better for SN2 reactions.
If you look at the relative rate
for displacement of
chloride by iodide in acetone,
if you call it 1 for propyl
chloride, if you make allyl
chloride, so you put a double
bond to make the carbon-chlorine
bond allylic,
it goes up by almost a 100 fold,
a factor of 90.
And, if it's a benzene ring
instead of just a regular old
double bond, it goes up another
factor of 2.5.
So, apparently this adjacent
unsaturation, that new double
bond, is especially good in
stabilizing at
the transition state.
So at the time when chloride is
leaving, and iodide is
coming in, the double bond is
able to interact with that
orbital that's bonding
simultaneously, that
pentavalent carbon transition
state.
So both SN2 as well as SN1,
where you draw a resonance
structure for that kind of
interaction, for the cation.
It's good to have it allylic.
Notice that this shift, this
allylic shift from isopentenyl
pyrophosphate to dimethylallyl
pyrophosphate,
resulted in getting the leaving
group to be allylic,
so it'll be easier to displace.
Why do you do that?
So you can take as a nucleophile
then, if you have
this really good leaving group,
you can take as a
nucleophile the isopentenyl
pyrophosphate, so it's a
carbon that's serving as the
nucleophile.
So you make a new bond, get a
cation, but the cation can be
lost by losing a proton next
door to make a new double
bond, which you'll notice is a
new allylic functionality with
a leaving group.
So you put two of these things
together, and you have the
same kind of functionality you
had at the beginning.
That thing is called geranyl
pyrophosphate, because it's
related to geraniums, as well
see.
Notice that the starting
material has five carbons, now
having put two together, you
have ten.
So if you take geranyl
pyrophosphate, and isomerize
the double bond, then it's in a
position for the other
double bond in the same molecule
to be the
nucleophile.
So you can do that, and get that
cation.
What could that cation do?
Well, of course it could do the
same thing it did before,
and lose a proton, and that
gives limonene, and I made it
sort of yellow-green, you know
why?
To make it a little bit like
lemons or limes.
Lemon grass oil has limonene in
it, Asian cooking has that.
If you bend it up, then you can
see another possibility.
What other possibility do you
see if I draw the conformation
more like that?
Anurag you got an idea?
STUDENT: Bridging?
PROFESSOR: Right, that double
bond could add to the vacant
orbital on the carbon, like
that, a Markovnikov addition.
Why is it not so good, Anurag?
STUDENT: Steric. For steric
reasons.
PROFESSOR: It forms a
four-membered ring, so there's
going to be some ring strain
there.
But it does happen.
If you lose the proton now, you
get a compound called
beta-pinene.
Guess what kind of trees that
comes from?
Now you could also do an
anti-Markovnikov addition,
which doesn't form quite as
strained a ring.
If you do that, and then add
water, and lose a proton to
the carbon cation, you get after
oxidation, camphor.
Now all these things have in
common that they have very
characteristic odors, the lemon,
the
pinene, turpentine, camphor.
So these things are called
terpenes, essential oils.
Terpene is from turpentine,
that's where pinene is the
major constituent of turpentine.
Essential oils doesn't mean you
need them, what it means
is they have an essence, they
have an odor, so these C10's
are volatile, and your nose
responds to them.
These are essential oils, and
notice they're C10's,
terpenes are C10's.
Now you can do more of the same,
if you start with your
geranyl pyrophosphate that you
had before, you could add
another isopentenyl
pyrophosphate, and get a thing
that's called farnesyl
pyrophosphate.
And things that come from that,
like the compounds that
came from the C10, were called
terpenes, these are called
sesquiterpenes.
Do you know what sesqui- means?
Do you know what a
sesquicentennial is?
Sesqui-, anybody?
It means one and a half, so it's
one and a
half terpenes, 15.
It's actually three of the
isopentenyl pyrophosphates,
but the name terpene came first.
So, for example,
caryophyllene, which is in
clove, and hemp, and rosemary,
is a sesquiterpene.
Now, two of those things can
come together, and now this
reaction is different, because
it's not the double bond
attacking, it's two of these
allylic positions coupling
with one another.
It's a different kind of
reaction, we're not going to
talk about it.
But, it couples to give this,
which is squalene,
or shark liver oil.
You see the new bond in the
middle, it's symmetric about
the middle.
You can do interesting things
with squalene.
What kind of terpene would you
call it
incidentally, squalene?
If you take two 15's, you get
30.
So, what are you going to call
it?
Is it a monoterpene,
sesquiterpene, diterpene?
It's a triterpene, two one and a
half's is three, so this is
a triterpene.
They're a lot more important
triterpenes, well more
important, they come from this,
so this one is a
starting point.
There's squalene, and I'm going
to twist it around into
a special conformation like
that.
What allows me to do that?
Enzymes that hold these things
in particular shapes.
Now, I'm going to react it with
oxygen and do an
epoxidation, of course it's not
just O, it's something
like the reagents we talked
about, except it's done
biologically.
But, we're not interested in the
particulars of the
biological reagent, but it makes
an expoxide.
Notice that it's able to do it
selectively, it gets only that
double bond among all those.
Now you protonate that, and what
will it do?
Can you see a way this can
become more stable?
What makes it unstable?
Chris?
STUDENT: Ring strain.
PROFESSOR: The ring strain.
How do you get rid of the ring
strain?
Which way are you going to break
it?
STUDENT: Which side?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you're either
going to break this bond, or
this bond, or this bond.
One, two, three.
STUDENT: Two.
PROFESSOR: Two, why two?
STUDENT: Better stability.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: Why better stability?
Notice that what's happened,
these electrons that are
shared between O and carbon are
going to
come onto the oxygen.
STUDENT: It's a better
carbocation.
PROFESSOR: Right, it's a
tertiary carbon cation if you
break it your way.
OK, so we'll do it that way.
Now, what's that going to do?
Anybody got an idea?
Natalie, what have we been
looking at
attacking double bonds?
We're looking at carbon cations
attacking double
bonds, any possibilities you
see?
STUDENT: It could attack the
double bonds.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now, you're going to form a bond
between this cation and
either the bottom one or the top
one.
Which one do you want to go to,
bottom or top, if you have
a cation adding to an alkene?
STUDENT: Bottom.
PROFESSOR: Why bottom?
Who would say that's a good
idea?
STUDENT: Markovnikov.
PROFESSOR: Markovnikov would say
it's a good idea.
You're right, so we do a
Markovnikov addition.
What happens next?
Noelle, you got an idea?
STUDENT: The same.
PROFESSOR: Do the same thing
again, do
another Markovnikov addition.
What's next?
Wrong, this time it's an
anti-Markovnikov addition,
because of the way the molecule
is held there.
But, now you're set up to do
another one,
a Markovnikov one.
Now you might think you'd use
that last double bond and make
another ring, since you're on a
roll here.
But you don't, and the reason is
the way the molecule is
held, so that that one's not in
position to do the trick.
But, something else happens.
Notice that's nice and stable,
it's a tertiary cation, but
there's another tertiary cation
available.
Do you see how to get to it?
Sebastian, you got an idea?
How can I get from this cation
to a different tertiary
cation, one that would be just
as stable.
STUDENT: Hydride shift.
PROFESSOR: Hydride shift, good.
So that's tertiary, but we can
do a hydride shift, and get
another tertiary one.
Any ideas for the next one?
Lauren, you got an idea?
We've got a nice stable tertiary
cation.
We can go back there, probably.
Any other possibilities of
getting it a tertiary one?
STUDENT: The one to the left.
PROFESSOR: The one on the left,
you could do another hydride
shift. So that's tertiary, too.
What's next?
Arvind, you got an idea?
STUDENT: You might as well just
do the methide.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the methide
shift.
OK, good.
Next, Antonia?
STUDENT: Another methide shift.
PROFESSOR: Another methide
shift, we're
really going to town.
Now what?
STUDENT: Hydride shift.
PROFESSOR: Hydride shift,
obviously, right?
Wrong.
This time the proton just gets
lost, so it goes that way, the
arrow, makes a double bond and
the proton goes away.
Now that stuff is lanosterol and
that's the source of
cholesterol and all the steroid
hormones.
Remember these few things we
showed last time that Barton
was looking at, all these
steroids?
They have a 6-membered,
6-membered, 6-membered ring
and then a 5-membered ring, and
something
substituted at the top.
They all come from here.
These are triterpenes.
Now that's a cute story, but one
wonders whether it's true?
We'll show how you know it's
true, once we get to NMR
spectroscopy, the week after
next, probably.
But, you'll have to hold your
breath until then.
So, these isoprenes then, you
can think about rearranging
those double bonds.
Notice that isopentenyl
pyrophosphate has this C5 unit
in, but if you do that you can
make two new bonds.
I'm not talking about
cation/anion mechanisms, just
schematic here.
If you have two isoprenes you
could link it together like
that, and that's geraniol, rose
oil, or you can have two
isoprenes and put them together
like
that, and that's menthol.
Or, you could have of four of
them, and put them together
like that, and that's retinal,
the aldehyde over on the
right, so that's the thing
that's involved in vision, or
that absorbs light in your eyes.
So it's a tetramer.
Or, you can take 30,000
isoprenes, and link them
together like that, and that's
latex.
The Latin word latex just meant
a liquid, but now it's
always applied to this
particular liquid, the sap
that runs out of these trees,
the Hevea brasiliensis.
There's a real romantic story
about this, and how explorers
stole seeds from Brazil, which
was trying to keep them, and
took them to England and grew
them in Kew, and then sent
them to southeast Asia to make
rubber plantations like this.
The rubber plantations in Brazil
failed because once you
put the trees all close
together, so that you can
harvest them efficiently, rather
than sending slaves out
into the Amazon to find a tree
here and a tree there, then it
turned out they got a disease
that killed all the ones down
in South America.
Henry Ford had a real disaster
with that.
Anyhow, you get that sap, and we
showed you the sap last
time, and we made a rubber ball
with it like this.
Now, that stuff was called by
the Indians, caoutchouc, and
in fact that's the name for
rubber in French.
So people tried to find a use
for it in the west, you know
the natives made balls, they
made galoshes, you know you
put your foot down in latex and
let it dry, and then
you've got a rubber boot.
There were lots of things, but
it was difficult to work with.
Thomas Hancock in England
developed a thing called a
"masticator" to try to chew it
up to make it so you could
make different things with it.
Charles Macintosh in Scotland in
1823 sandwiched the rubber
between cloth layers to make
waterproofs, you know that's
what you call a waterproof
jacket in
Britain is a Macintosh.
The reason you had to sandwich
it, was because the stuff is
really sticky.
I had a piece I was going to
bring that I made last time,
and I forgot to, but it's really
sticky stuff.
So, that's not so good.
It gets really gooey in the
heat, and it's brittle in the
cold, so there's a fairly narrow
temperature range where
it's useful.
Until Charles Goodyear in 1839
figured out the process of
vulcanization, which made this
stuff useful.
This is his own description from
his autobiography in 1855
of the discovery of
vulcanization.
He actually, he was really nuts
about rubber.
Incidentally, the word rubber
was coined by Priestley, the
guy who discovered oxygen.
You know why?
Because you use it for an eraser
to rub out pencil
marks, so "rubber."
Anyhow, Goodyear really loved
rubber.
In this book, he printed several
copies on paper, but
other copies he printed on
rubber, which is now all stuck
together and you can't open any
of the pages.
Anyhow, in describing his
discovery, he said "he," that
is himself, speaking in the
third person here. "He was
surprised to find that the
specimen, being carelessly
brought into contact with a hot
stove, charred like
leather." He was trying to
figure some way to make it not
be sticky, so he thought you
could put a powder on it to
keep it from being sticky.
The powder he was trying was
sulfur, but he was in Woburn,
Mass, when he was doing this,
and he dropped it on a hot
stove, and it charred, whereas
usually it melted.
This surprised him, so he got
his friends and relations.
It says, "He endeavoured to call
the attention of his
brother, as well as some other
individuals who were present,
and who were acquainted with the
manufacturer of gum
elastic, to this effect, as
remarkable, and unlike any
before known, since gum elastic
always melted when
exposed to a high degree of
heat.
The occurrence did not at the
time seem to them to be worthy
of notice; it was considered as
one of the frequent appeals
that he was in the habit of
making, in behalf of some new
experiment." So, they're tired
of all his inventions.
But, he showed it to Benjamin
Silliman at Yale.
And Silliman wrote, "Having seen
experiments made, and
also performed them myself, with
the India rubber prepared
by Mr. Charles Goodyear, I can
state that it does not melt,
but rather chars, by heat, and
that it does not stiffen by
cold, but retains its
flexibility with cold, even
when laid between cakes of ice."
So this is what
Goodyear, who didn't have much
money, needed in terms of a
serious endorsement, to go out
and try to get some capital to
commercialize this.
So, he got a patent, and this is
the
beginnings of the patent.
He says, he claims "combining
said gum with sulphur and with
white lead, so as to form a
triple compound," the lead's
not used anymore, "in
combination with the forgoing,
the process of exposing the
india-rubber fabric, to the
action of a high degree of
heat." He had made a whole
bunch of raincoats, sort of
Macintosh style, and had put
them in the closet during the
summer to bring out when it
got rainy again, and when he
went to get them, they were
just all one big gooey mass.
So this was really appealing to
him, to patent this, so he
could make fabric from it.
This is 1844.
Seven years later was the
Crystal Palace exhibition in
London, the triumph of industry
in the West, in the
Victorian Period.
There were these industrial
displays of the best products
from all over the world, and
here only seven years after
the patent, we find Goodyear's
Vulcanite Court, where he's
pushing the beauties of rubber.
You see, there's a desk, and
that desk is made of rubber,
and it still exists, it's in a
museum up in Waterbury.
He made everything out of
rubber, you can't believe all
the things he made out of
rubber.
He proposed making bills for
currency out of rubber, so
that you could wash them without
destroying them.
A lot of these things didn't
catch on.
Anyhow, latex is this polymer.
What do you do when you heat it
with sulfur?
Well, you have several chains
next to one another, and no
one knows exactly how it works.
But, somehow it joins adjacent
chains with sulfur to make
cross-links between these
polymer chains.
Probably there are radical
addition reactions to double
bonds, radical allylic
substitutions, so you get
maybe this allylic radical,
which attacks the sulfur, and
then that adds to the other
double bond,
something like this.
But, anyhow, it makes
cross-links in the chains.
How does that affect the
physical
properties of the polymers?
Remember the problem is that it
gets gooey when it's hot,
and brittle when it's cold,
which is not what
you want in a coat.
We're going to study this a
little bit, and we're going to
follow a really important
scientist who
published this in 1803.
"A Description of a Property of
Caoutchouc, or Indian
Rubber; with some Reflections on
the Cause of Elasticity of
this Substance." So this was
done by John
Gough, who lived 1757-1825.
He was a very interesting
person.
He tutored John Dalton for
example, he lived up in the
Lake District in England.
And Wordsworth wrote of him in
this poem, "Excursion, "No
floweret blooms throughout the
lofty range of these rough
hills, nor in the woods, that
could from him conceal its
birth-place; none whose figure
did not live upon his touch. "
"Touch" because when Gough was
three years old, he had
rheumatic fever and went blind.
He was a great scientist, though
blind. So everything he
had to do by touch, or
description of someone else.
So all these studies of rubber,
he did blind.
Here's the beginning of this.
He lived in Middleshaw House,
near Kendal in 1802.
He said, "The substance called
caoutchouc, or Indian Rubber,
possesses a singular property;
which, I believe has never
been taken notice of in print,
at least by any English
Writer." So, here it goes on,
and he says, "I made a piece
of caoutchouc a little heavier
than an equal bulk of water,
the temperature of which was 45
degrees: the vessel
containing the resin and water
was then placed on the fire,
and when the contents of it were
heated to 130 degrees,
the caoutchouc floated on the
surface."
What does that say about the
density of Caoutchouc, and the
influence of heat on it?
Mary?
STUDENT: It got less dense.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: It got less dense,
right?
Because you know water gets less
dense
when you heat it up.
So, when it was cold it sank,
when it was hot it floated.
So it must expand, when you heat
it, more than water does.
Heating rubber makes it expand
more than water.
That's the first. That's not a
great surprise, that's not the
important thing.
Experiment one is the important
thing.
Here he says, "Hold one end of
the slip, of the rubber, thus
prepared, between the thumb and
forefinger of each hand;
bring the middle of the piece
into slight contact with the
edges of the lips"; because he
has to do it by touch, "taking
care to keep it straight all the
time, but not to stretch
it much beyond its natural
length: after taking these
preparatory steps, extend the
slip suddenly; and you will
immediately perceive"--
something.
We're going to repeat his thing,
but I need a balloon.
Everybody take their balloon,
and we'll do what Gough says
to do here.
Hold it between your thumb and
finger, and put it against
your upper lip, and stretch it a
little bit.
Now, having stretched it a
little bit, stretch it as hard
as you can while it's against
your lip.
Do you notice anything?
Who's as sensitive as John Gough
here?
What happened?
What's really interesting is,
you stretch it pretty far and
not much happens, but the last
inch makes a difference.
You notice that?
What happened, Lauren?
STUDENT: It just got really
warm.
PROFESSOR: It got really warm,
not in the first part of the
stretching, but at the very end
of the stretching.
Is everybody on to that?
Good, so that's what he noticed,
and you can read all
that he said here if you want
to.
Then, he tries another
experiment here.
He says, "If one end of a slip
of Caoutchouc be fastened to a
rod of metal or wood, and a
weight be fixed to the other
extremity, in order to keep it
in a vertical position," then
what will the thong do?
So, let's try that one.
Here's a piece of caoutchouc.
We'll get it so you can see it
here.
There, you can see it a little
bit, but
we'll need some light.
We'll put this on here.
We're going to stretch it,
that's what he says to do.
I had more, when I tried this, I
had more light before.
Let's see if I can do better.
I'll turn on this light, there
we go, except that the thing
is blocking it.
I'm getting it into focus.
So, I have lines on paper there,
and you can see how
much it's stretched.
Now, what he's going to do is
heat it.
What does caoutchouc do when you
heat it?
What's going to happen to the
weight?
We see the weight just halfway
down below one of those lines.
What's going to happen when I
heat it?
I'll heat it with this thing.
Which way will it move?
STUDENT: It will move down.
PROFESSOR: It'll expand, right.
So, let's give it a try.
Is it going down?
Did it do anything?
It may be that it's, let me
slide it out a little bit
here, so that it's not rubbing
against the rod, there.
What do you think?
Derek?
STUDENT: It shrivels.
PROFESSOR: What's going to
happen if I cool it off?
STUDENT: It should go back.
PROFESSOR: Let's watch.
It's expanding when it cools,
and it's contracting slowly
when it heats.
This is weird, right?
It expands when it cools, and
contracts when it heats.
We're going to have to deal with
that.
Heating a tightly stretched
piece of
rubber makes it contract.
If stretching rubber generates
heat, that's what we did here.
Let's think a second.
What's going to happen when it
contracts, if
we let it go back?
Well, we have several
possibilities.
It could be that the heat comes
from friction of the
molecules rubbing by one
another.
If that's so, what would happen
when we let it contract?
Karl?
STUDENT: It heats either way.
PROFESSOR: It will heat either
way.
On the other hand, if heat comes
from some other cause,
contraction may do the opposite
and absorb heat.
So, what we're going to do is
stretch our rubber as far as
we can and go like this to get
it back to room temperature,
while holding it tightly,
tightly stretched because
remember this phenomenon happens
only at the very end.
Then we're going to put it
against our lip, and do that.
What do you find?
Which of these is it, one or
two?
Did it get hot when it
contracted,
or did it get cold?
Both, did someone say?
Cold, OK.
That's pretty dramatic, isn't
it?
Gough claims to having
discovered this, but in fact,
I discovered it.
My nephew was having a birthday,
and I was blowing up
balloons, and I happened to do
that.
I thought, wow, that's really
something.
[LAUGHTER]
Then I found out I had been
scooped by two centuries.
How does this work?
What the heck is going on with
these polymers?
Have you been to Yale Health
Center?
What do you see, if you go up in
the Yale Health Center and
look out toward the campus?
This is what you see, a rather
questionable view from the
Yale Health Center.
But, right here is something
that's very interesting, and
if you get up and look at it,
that's the tomb of Charles
Goodyear, because he was a
native of New Haven, even
though he discovered
vulcanization in Woburn, Mass,
and died in New York, a pauper
incidentally.
A pauper because he got involved
with lawyers. People
tried, everybody and his brother
tried to break his
patent. So he hired Daniel
Webster, who was Secretary of
State, and put on the most
expensive defense that ever
happened of a patent, and still
he lost his shirt.
He didn't know how it worked,
but maybe he can find out now,
because there he is, and if you
go to that obelisk there,
and then down just a little bit
farther, you get to this
guy. And that guy could tell
him, probably, and
conceivably, did talk to him,
because this is J. Willard
Gibbs who got his a Bachelor's
degree at Yale in 1858, so two
years before Goodyear died.
So they could have met, but I
don't think they did.
Gibbs could have given him some
idea about what was going
on with rubber.
But, the persons who really
could have done
it, are over here.
Here are two gravestones that
have different designs,
they're both people from this
Chemistry Department.
One is John Gamble Kirkwood, who
was a physical chemist and
a theorist about polymers.
His gravestone tells everything
he did, not
everything, but quite a few
things, the awards
he got and so on.
Next to his, is the tomb of Lars
Onsager, his friend and
colleague, and his tomb says,
Nobel Laureate.
His wife died 15 years later,
and the stone was recarved to
put her name on it as well, and
also to put on a footnote.
[LAUGHTER]
Perhaps they're communing down
there with Goodyear now, and
telling him what's going on with
this.
It has to do with statistical
mechanics, you remember,
that's what Gibbs did, because
statistics is what makes
rubber contract after you've
stretched it.
If you have a chain all
stretched out like this,
there's only one way to arrange
it
between the two ends.
But, if you contract it, like
that, you can have it that
way, or that way, or that way,
or that way, or that way.
There's a zillion ways to have
it if it's contracted, so
statistics, entropy says, it
wants to have a shorter
distance between the ends.
Even though it might be most
stable, in terms of heat, that
is, the best conformation when
it's stretched out, entropy
will contract it again.
If you have a whole bunch of
these polymer chains, then you
start to stretch them out,
they're all tangled around,
and as you stretch, they get
more and more parallel to one
another, and finally, they'll
get so near, some of them will
get near one another enough, to
crystallize, just locally.
I mean, these aren't like
diamonds, right.
But, little local units of the
thing are together, and when
they come together like that,
they're lower in energy, so
they give off heat.
So, when you stretch it, at
first it doesn't make any
difference, but the very last
bit of the stretching causes
this crystallization, and heat
comes out.
There's local crystallization
which contributes rigidity and
releases heat.
On the other hand, if you put
heat in, it will melt these
crystals, and entropy will cause
it to contract.
So, then it will allow
statistics to make the
material contract like this, and
you'll go backwards.
So it's actually entropy that
brings rubber back to its
original shape.
Fixed, irregular cross-links
between adjacent chains
prevents crystallization, so it
doesn't become brittle when
it's cold, because it doesn't
crystallize.
It also prevents it from being
gooey when it's hot.
How does that happen?
The gooeyness has to do with the
flowing of the molecules,
but if you have something that's
all tangled up like
this, how can you move a
molecule, if it's got a really
complicated shape?
The way it happens is very
interesting.
It's a process called reptation,
like a reptile.
This was an idea of a French
physicist who got the Nobel
Prize for this kind of thing.
So, suppose you try to move the
chain lengthwise, what
will happen is, like a carpet,
when you try to move a carpet,
you make a little wiggle in it,
a little hump.
Then you could move the hump
along, without moving anything
else, and it would go on and on
all along the chain, and
finally get to the other end,
where it would be like that,
and finally the other end could
move.
So, it sort of crawls, or goes
like a snake, through all this
tangle of other polymers.
What does vulcanization have to
do with that?
If you have cross-links between
the chains, then they
can't slide by one another, so
you can't do reptation, so the
stuff doesn't flow and become
gooey when it's hot.
That's what vulcanization does,
so there's no flow when
hot, and it inhibits
crystallization, so it's not
brittle when it's cold.
There's also vulcanization that
happens in the home.
As I look around, I'm not sure
that any of you have practiced
this, but you've heard of it,
I'm sure.
Here's Robin Kelly.
I got permission to use this by
talking to Robin Kelly's
mother, and she tells me that
Robin Kelly is now a student
at Harvard Law School, this was
from some years ago.
But, Robin Kelly did Irish
dancing, and she wanted her
hair to look like this, for
Irish dancing.
So, she vulcanized it.
Hair has sulfide groups coming
out, and they link to other
chains, so it's cross-linked,
it's vulcanized to begin with,
that holds the chains next to
one another in shape.
So what she did first, was
reduce the disulfide
cross-links by excess basic
thiol.
These are the two thiols that
are commonly used for that,
and notice that the SH is much
more acidic than hydroxide.
So if you have basic RSH, you
have RS-.
So, that could do an SN2
reaction on sulfur and break
that bond, and that one can
attack another thiol, take its
hydrogen, and then that thiolate
anion can do another
displacement.
So what's happened, is that
we've reduced the disulfide
links to make it two RSH groups.
You can do the same thing again,
and again, and again,
and now the chains are pliable,
and can be moved past
one another.
So now she puts the soft spikes
in, and curls her hair
up tight, and changes it shape.
Now she's got to make new
cross-links again, to
vulcanize it, so she's got it
like this.
Now she oxidizes the thiols back
to disulfide with
hydrogen peroxide.
Now look at the bond
dissociation energies.
The OH-OH, remember, the O-O is
a very weak bond, but the S-S
bond is not so weak, and S-H
bond is weak, compared to O-H.
So, it's much favorable, to
start on the left
and go to the right.
It's favorable by 30
kilocalories per mole.
So, if she puts in peroxide,
with thiol, she'll get out the
new cross-links and alcohol.
So you get the new cross-links
holding the chains together in
the shape you want them to be.
So now her hair is vulcanized,
and everything's fine, and she
can go Irish dancing.
Another way to hold the chains
together with cross-links is
to have ionic groups on them.
These ions tend to get together
with counterions in
clusters, so that serves as a
cross-link, but it's not a
permanent cross-link the way
covalent bonds are.
It's possible, if you warm it,
to break those, and make
things flow.
This is thermoplastic. You heat
the polymer, and you can
reshape it, then you cool it,
and then
it's got the new shape.
So there's after warming, and
they got malleable
cross-links.
This is Father Nieuwland at
Notre Dame University, who
figured out how to polymerize
not the thing that had methyl
up here, which was the
biological isoprene unit, but
the one that has chloro, so that
gave a new compound
called neoprene, which had
different properties.
They're all these different
polymers that have been made,
and this list of according to
how much they cost, they get
very expensive for
fluorosilicone, how heat
resistant they are, at low
temperature, and the maximum
temperature you can use them.
Also, how they last, oxidation,
whether they're
subject to weathering by ozone,
how strong they are.
So, natural rubber is nice and
strong, it resists abrasion
and tear, it's very resilient,
this is after cross-linking
it, after vulcanization, but
it's only fair on
oxidation or ozone.
You've probably seen rubber
that's been around awhile, or
old telephone lines, the rubber
is falling off because
ozone has gotten to it.
They're others that have a
variety of properties, and
also an important one that's not
listed here, is how they
interact with oil or something
like that.
Natural rubber is very bad with
oil, but some of these
others, like neoprene is much
better.
Designing a tire for your car is
a very complex thing, to
mix different polymers to get
exactly the properties in
different parts of the tire that
are necessary.
There are other ways of doing
polymerization as well, for
example, styrene, you could
imagine these double bonds
going together with a radical
doing addition
to that double bond.
Notice that as I drew it there,
it's random which end
of the styrene got attacked. But
it would also be possible
to imagine that it always goes
head to tail,
always the same way.
Why would that be advantageous,
always to go this way?
Because in fact, that's what it
does.
It goes just head to tail.
Why?
Why don't you do additions like
this, where you add to
the center and leave that
radical?
Why do you want to leave this
radical instead?
Amy?
STUDENT: It's secondary.
PROFESSOR: It's secondary, but
much more important, it's
benzylic, it's like allylic. It
has the double bonds to
interact with the SOMO.
For both reasons it does that,
even if it were a methyl
group, it would tend to do this,
because it would be
secondary the way Amy said.
But with phenyl, it's ever so
much more so, so that's 13
kilocalories more stable, than
adding the other way.
There's also the question of
tacticity, which
we talked on before.
You can have isotactic--
these are all head to tail,
notice, the methyl group is on
every other carbon.
But you can have isotactic,
syndiotactic, where isotactic
they're all the same,
syndiotactic they alternate,
and atactic is random.
That's what you get, the
regiochemistry is always head
to tail with the free radical,
but the stereochemistry is
random, so it's atactic.
But, you can get isotactic
polypropylene from
Ziegler-Natta catalyst, that we
talked about last lecture
or the lecture before and
syndiotactic, remember, if use
this fancy Kaminsky catalyst,
that comes from one side, then
the other, then one side, and
then the other, and it has a
mirror plane, so you change the
configuration each time.
There's another question of
selectivity when you have two
different monomers in there, for
example methyl
methacrylate and styrene. So you
could have block
copolymers, where you have a
bunch of one coming together,
and then a bunch of the other
one in a single chain.
Another possibility is to have
them strictly alternate, A B A
B A B, and you can do that. And
the reason you can do it,
is because of the rates of
adding different radicals to
the alkenes.
So, if you have that particular
radical at the end
of the chain, it adds to styrene
faster than it adds to
methyl methacrylate.
This unit here was methyl
methacrylate that added to a
radical there, so now it's at
the end of the chain, and it
would prefer by a factor of two
to one to react with its
own kind, pardon me, to react
with styrene rather than with
it's own kind.
What would you expect if you
have
styrene as the last radical?
Notice what's interesting, here.
I was wondering what this one
was here, it's this.
Now notice it's a factor of two
in the other direction.
One radical--
each radical, prefers to react
with the other monomer, isn't
that interesting.
That's why it goes A B A B A B.
Why should that be?
This isn't surprising, because
this radical is resonance-
stabilized as Amy was telling
us.
That's the fastest of all these
reactions, and it's a
good radical, so that's
reasonable.
But why does this one prefer not
to form the good radical,
but to form what appears to be
the less good radical?
Here's our radical starting, and
it can add to this, to
give that, and that turns out it
would be something like
that, and it's 20 kilocalories
per mole exothermic.
If we react with the other
alkene, then it gives this,
which is less stable.
This one doesn't have as much
allylic or benzylic
stabilization that you have down
here.
But, it's faster.
So it's faster to go to the
higher-energy product. That's
not the Hammond postulate,
right?
Why?
Why is it twice as fast to go to
the less stable product?
The transition state for one
looks like that, the
transition state for the other
looks like that.
What's good about the bottom
one?
There's the top one, there's the
bottom one, and notice in
this one the carbonyl is good at
stabilizing high HOMOs.
So, you could have a resonance
structure with a minus charge
here, and a plus charge here.
You can't do that up here as
well, this isn't specifically
good at stabilizing anions.
So you could have these
resonance structures here,
that you can't have there.
So, the ionic resonance
structure, you could say,
stabilizes the transition state,
or if you wanted to
talk about it in terms of
orbitals, you'd say that the C
double bond O gives an unusually
low LUMO, so that's
good when the SOMO is not so
low.
This special stability applies
only at the transition state.
Once you've formed this bond,
then you can't have a
resonance structure like that.
The product is not stabilized by
that kind of thing, but the
transition state is, which is
what makes these things turn
around and go A B A B A B. OK,
now I was going to go on to
acetylenes, but we'll do that
next time.